Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so there's new
footage we learned are little about the villain
of the movie series Ares even though we haven't
seen him at least as we know in the footage.
there is a new round of the flash ring giveaway
going on.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
Previous winners are announced at the end
be sure to click that bell to enable alerts
so you don't miss anything.
So you new footage the actors are talking
about the film there were five big takeaways
and it's all about wonder woman's origin story
and how that feeds into her ongoing conflict
with her main villain Ares, so number five
her origin story is kind of a mess when you
go like way back in the comics is kind of
the same problem you have with a lot of comic
book characters.
That's why the other having rebirth right
now is sort of reimagining the characters
leaving all that continuity together and really
understandable simple way in the original
version of wonder woman's origin story, she
was created from a lump of clay by hope all
at the her mother and then given life by the
goddess Athena.
So each of the Greek gods bestowed upon her
their powers so she was like this a mall gum
creation like a golem that was created by
them but then later incarnations made her
the daughter of Zeus.
So it seems like what the movie has done is
sort of combined those two things in a really
simple way where she says she has no father.
She was created by Sue's so she's not like
the other Amazons even though she is an Amazon.
That's why they're all bad asses.
So you could consider them metahuman's, but
technically they're not metahuman this is
where you get into a lot of Greek and Roman
mythology try to weave that in with traditional
DC comics metahuman's people with powers,
but she is like a step above the other Amazons,
so number four learning the truth of things.
So in almost every version of her origin story.
She runs into Steve Trevor who is sort of
like the entry into the real world for her
where she learns what's really going on.
Like she's been isolated on this island in
the context of the movie the Amazons had sort
of bailed on humanity, but she's only been
around for part of their history, there's
this whole implied history that goes way back
further beyond that explains why the Amazons
bailed on humanity and how they rebelled against
Zeus why he's not around and why Ares is such
a villain, so number three Ares is typically
been her main villain.
He's the God of war he tries to create chaos
he hates humanity wants them to die.
So tries to find creative ways to make that
happen during the new 52 comics.
He even became her advisor Sir trying to co-opt
or so like I said, trying to learn the truth
of things.
Wonder woman wants to learn the truth about
what really happened what's really going on
with Ares and why the Amazons have the wrong
idea and should not have bailed on humanity.
The thing about Ares though is that in the
context of the DC extended universe is set
in the real world.
The man of steel movie was meant to be an
example of what would happen if an alien with
the powers of a God came to earth how people
react to that in the context of the wonder
woman movie.
They have to find a really practical way to
weave in all this Greek mythology.
So what would a God look like in the DC extended
universe, he would probably just look like
a normal person most of the time, but even
in the comics Ares can change for he can appear
as an old man he can appear as a young man
he can also show up in full battle armor and
change sides become this big hulking brute
empty that looks like they could take on wonder
woman instead of just a normal person, but
for the most part the way they're presenting
the wonder woman movie is that he's mostly
acting behind-the-scenes pulling strings trying
to orchestrate chaos and the downfall of humanity
through World War I in this weird gas that
they're playing with, so Doctor poison seems
like somebody who might be working with Ares.
We don't know if he's actually Danny Houston
in disguise then Houston is just like a great
character for playing villains so if we've
actually already seen Ares in the trailers
before and just not realize that he would
be the leading candidate.
They haven't confirmed anything in number
two ghetto back story of how Ares came to
power he's very powerful God but Zeus is more
powerful you have to get rid of Odin before
Loki could take over in the Thor movies.
So how do you get rid of Zeus.
So in the context of what the actors have
been saying in this version of events the
Amazons and Ares revolted against Zeus and
killed him.
So Zeus is either dead or gone basically sidelined
not present in the movie unit technically.
You can't really kill a God.
So that was actually a comic book during the
new 52 the try to address that problem, but
however they handle it in the movie Zeus is
not around and Ares is left to run amok the
reason for the revolt is that Ares was jealous
of man because Zeus favored them more, which
sounds very in keeping with Greek tragedy.
So that led to a revolt in the ancient history
of the Amazons.
So a big part of the movie is wonder woman
trying to learn the truth of things taking
the side of man over the Amazons and going
against Ares because she's of these people
so the Amazons had this way of life.
They taught her to believe certain things
within Steve Trevor comes he says you've never
met a man, so that just like so many things
that she's questioning in the movie, so she
tries to find her own truth and stop the world
from blowing itself apart which sets her against
Ares, but number one what is this say about
her fight with Ares going forward in movies
because Superman fought Zod in the first man
of steel movie.
He killed them at the end so that was a really
big deal.
Very controversial but Zod is technically
one of Superman's biggest villains like brainiac
is another one of Superman's biggest villains
Superman just has a lot more villains in his
rogues gallery there been fewer wonder woman
comics so fewer wonder woman villains of that
caliber that you would consider really good
pics for a movie.
So what they might do in future movies it
just allowed Ares to slink away so that he
can continue to trouble her if they do more
wonder woman sequels there probably gonna
wait till the wonder woman movie comes out
to decide what the future of that character
in spinoff movies is going to be of the gonna
do wonder woman to she just gonna be a Justice
league character think about what they did
with the Capt. America character somebody
that was pulled out of time like wonder woman
is an ancient character reflecting on how
she got to this point in a most of the movie
takes place in the past but then they jump
forward to the Justice league.
Just like Capt. America took place during
World War II that he was thrust in the modern
day in the continuity of the new Avengers
films, so that's probably what they would
do with wonder woman sequels they would all
be set in present-day with present-day villains.
So even in present day the gods are still
very much a problem for humanity.
So there's plenty of people that they could
pull for wonder woman to fight but I think
it just depends on where they leave the character
at the end of the wonder woman movie at the
end of Justice league.
The way the producers of been talking about
her is that she'll actually be fully actualized
by the time we get to Justice league if you've
ever read Superman red son, it's like of what
if story.
What if his pot had crashed in the Soviet
Union and just shows you that he's very prone
to influence of the people that he grows up
with the wonder woman is just trying to break
free of the influence of the only people that
she's ever known fit this dogma, so let me
know what you guys are most hype about wonder
woman versus Ares do you actually think that
will see him in his full Greek armor.
Do you think that will even seem in the movie
and all even if she's acting through other
agents like Doctor poison here really good
news to, they just confirm the Green Lantern
Corps movie is coming it's gonna be like lethal
weapon space will do a Justice league Green
Lantern video soon as a whole bunch other
comic book news will say congratulations to
this week's flash ring giveaway winner Quentyn
Revelation please private message me on the
back and my channel so I can get your contact
details.
There was a new round that started in this
video I'll just announce the winner the next
time I post a DC video what you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for my
top 50 characters are heading in infinity
war and you can click here to learn all about
my predictions for the back half of the flash
the season.
Thank you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see you guys tonight!